en este vídeo veremos la decisión de al
que nos usando una reacción llamada
autolisis aquí a mi izquierda tengo mi
al que no genérico y a ese al que no le
añadiremos o tres en el primer paso el
cual es ozono y en el segundo paso
añadiremos de ms el cual es sulfuro de
de metilo y ten cuidado porque hay
diferentes reactivos que podrías agregar
en el segundo paso así que asegúrate de
aprender el que tu profesor quiere usar
si usas de ms obtendrás una mezcla de
aldehídos y yo cetonas como tu producto
dependiendo de lo que esté unido actual
que no inicial empecemos viendo un
diagrama de puntos para el ozono aquí en
la izquierda hay un posible diagrama de
puntos para el ozono y podemos dibujar
una estructura resonante al tomar estos
electrones y movernos a acá para formar
un doble enlace entre esos dos oxígenos
y ahora empujo estos electrones de aquí
al oxígeno en la izquierda así que
continuamos dibujando la otra estructura
resonante
ahora tendría un doble enlace entre mis
dos oxígenos en la derecha
el oxígeno más a la derecha tiene dos
pares libres de electrones alrededor de
él ahora el oxígeno del centro aún tiene
un par libre de electrones en él y el
oxígeno más a la izquierda ahora tiene
tres pares libres de electrones en él el
oxígeno más a la izquierda
ahora tiene una carga formal de menos 1
y el oxígeno aquí arriba aún tiene una
carga formal de más 1 y entonces esas
son nuestras dos estructuras resonantes
recuerda que la molécula actual es un
híbrido de estas dos estructuras
resonantes continuamos tomando una de
esas estructuras resonantes y solo
tomaré la de la derecha déjame continuar
dibujando la nuevamente
la estructura resonante de la derecha
y haremos la que tiene la carga negativa
en el oxígeno que está más a la
izquierda y este oxígeno de arriba tiene
una carga formal de más 1 y el oxígeno
de la derecha no tiene carga en la
estructura resonante continuamos
dibujando nuestro al que no y entonces
aquí está nuestro al que no con
sustituye entes desconocidos por el
momento pensamos en nuestro mecanismo la
carga negativa en el oxígeno este par
libre de electrones de aquí atacar a
este carbono lo que empujará a estos
electrones pin y estos electrones pin de
hecho irán a este oxígeno de aquí el
cual empujará estos electrones pide aquí
a este oxígeno
por lo que hay un mecanismo concertado
aquí y entonces continuamos dibujando
los resultados de esos electrones
moviéndose el oxígeno en la izquierda
ahora está enlazado al carbono en la
izquierda el carbono en la izquierda
ahora tiene un enlace simple con el
carbono en la derecha el carbono en la
derecha ahora está enlazado a este
oxígeno y luego estos dos oxígenos están
unidos a un oxígeno en el centro para
los pares libres de electrones todos
nuestros oxígenos tendrán dos pares
libres de electrones
así
y entonces tuvimos demasiados electrones
moviéndose veamos si podemos seguir los
hagamos relaciones de colores algunos
electrones aquí diré que estos
electrones en azul esos son los que
formaron este enlace entre el oxígeno y
el carbono y diré que estos electrones
billy en rojo esos son los que formaron
este enlace entre este carbono y este
oxígeno y luego finalmente estos
electrones estoy diciendo que estos de
aquí son mis electrones
se moverán a este oxígeno de arriba
podría decir que esos electrones en
magenta estarán justo aquí y entonces
ahora tenemos esta estructura ahora los
enlaces oxígeno oxígeno son
relativamente débiles son inestables y
entonces tenemos dos enlaces oxígeno
oxígeno en esta molécula y uno de esos
enlaces oxígeno oxígeno se romperá en el
siguiente paso del mecanismo y entonces
podría escoger cualquiera ya que son
simétricos y sólo diré que sólo diré que
estos electrones de aquí diré que este
enlace oxígeno oxígeno se romperá en la
siguiente parte de nuestro mecanismo y
entonces si pensamos en estos electrones
en este oxígeno moviéndose
aquí eso rompería este enlace entre los
dos carbonos porque hay demasiados
enlaces en el carbono de la derecha este
enlace se romperá y empujará esos
electrones para acá
y luego estos electrones en verde se
irán al oxígeno de arriba por lo que
nuestro enlace inestable oxígeno oxígeno
se rompe continuamos dibujando lo que
obtendríamos
en el lado izquierdo tenemos un carbono
y ahora ese carbono tendrá dos enlaces
al oxígeno y el oxígeno tendrá dos pares
libres de electrones para un compuesto
carbónico en la derecha el carbono de la
derecha está unido a otros dos átomos o
moléculas y ahora tiene un enlace doble
con este oxígeno de aquí
y ahora este oxígeno sólo tiene un par
libre de electrones en él y luego este
oxígeno está unido al otro oxígeno y ese
oxígeno ahora tiene tres pares libres de
electrones lo que le dará una carga
formal negativa tenemos una carga formal
negativa aquí este oxígeno de aquí
obtiene una carga formal de más 1 y
formamos un óxido de carbón y lo en la
derecha este compuesto cargado en la
derecha es llamado óxido de carbón y lo
en el siguiente paso del mecanismo si
pensamos en el compuesto carbónico de la
izquierda esté compuesto carbónico aquí
en la izquierda el enlace doble entre
oxígeno y carbono
el oxígeno es más electro negativo que
el carbono por lo que el oxígeno jalar a
esos electrones más cerca de él para
darle al oxígeno una carga parcial
negativa el carbono perderá algo de
densidad electrónica por lo que este
carbono tendrá una carga parcial
positiva y puedes ver que tienes este
oxígeno con una carga parcial negativa
justo al lado de un oxígeno cargado
negativamente en el óxido de carbón hilo
y entonces esos por supuesto se repeler
a le daremos la vuelta a este compuesto
carbónico en la izquierda le daremos
vuelta a este compuesto en la izquierda
y dibujar el óxido de carbón y lo en la
derecha de la misma forma mientras
continuamos nuestro mecanismo
daremos fuerza al compuesto carbónico en
la izquierda
y conservaremos el óxido de carbón y lo
igual
y la misma orientación así y continuamos
poniendo todos nuestros pares libres de
electrones
y cargas formales
hay una carga formal negativa aquí carga
formal positiva aquí y dos pares libres
de electrones en este oxígeno hagamos un
poco más de espacio por aquí y
nuevamente podemos pensar en que nuestro
compuesto carbónico se ha polarizado
cierto el oxígeno es parcialmente
negativo y este carbono de aquí es
parcialmente positivo y entonces en el
siguiente paso del mecanismo obtendremos
un ataque en núcleo físico tendremos que
este oxígeno cargado negativamente
atacar a este carbón o parcialmente
positivo justo aquí y si el oxígeno
forma un enlace con este carbono
eso serían demasiados enlaces a este
carbono y entonces este par libre de
electrones estos electrones pi de aquí
irán atrás de este carbono el cual
empujará a estos electrones de aquí a
ese oxígeno y nuevamente tenemos muchos
electrones moviéndose
veamos si podemos continuar dibujando el
producto y ver si podemos seguir esos
electrones un poco ahora tendremos este
carbono de aquí unido a un oxígeno este
oxígeno ahora está unido a lo que solía
ser nuestro carbono óxido de carbón y lo
este carbono está unido a otros dos
átomos o moléculas y también está unido
a un oxígeno y ese oxígeno está unido a
un oxígeno que ahora está unido a este
carbono déjame continuar y poner
nuestros pares libres de electrones
cada uno de nuestros oxígenos tendrá dos
pares libres de electrones así y
nuevamente veamos si podemos seguir a
esos electrones porque sucedieron
demasiadas cosas
continuemos siguiendo estos electrones
aquí en azul
a aquellos en el oxígeno cargado
negativamente esos son los que atacarán
núcleo físicamente ese carbono carbónico
justo aquí y formarán este enlace
este enlace en azul representa a esos
electrones azules bien
si seguimos estos electrones y aquí
estos electrones bill en este carbón
hilo en rojo éstos formarán un enlace
entre este oxígeno y este carbono así y
luego finalmente estos electrones pide
aquí en el óxido de carbón y los se
moverán esos electrones se moverán a
este oxígeno así
y entonces ahora tenemos este compuesto
eso es todo para el primer paso cierto
añadir o sólo a nuestro al que no y
ahora podemos continuar con nuestro
sulfuro de dimetil o el sulfuro de
dimetil o bien continuemos dibujando eso
aquí tenemos un azufre y luego ese
azufre está unido a dos grupos metilo y
el azufre tiene dos pares libres de
electrones así y entonces uno de esos
pares libres en el azufre atacar a este
oxígeno de aquí un par libre atacará a
este oxígeno y otra vez tenemos un
enlace débil oxígeno oxígeno cierto
déjame ver si puedo resaltar ese enlace
débil oxígeno oxígeno justo aquí
está nuestro enlace débil oxígeno
oxígeno que se romperá y esos electrones
se moverán para acá y esos serían
demasiados enlaces a este carbono estos
electrones en rojo se moverán para acá y
luego finalmente los electrones en azul
regresarán a ese oxígeno de arriba
continuamos dibujando continuamos
dibujando eso bien ahora que pasa ahora
tendremos tendremos un carbono aquí en
la izquierda ahora está doblemente
enlazado a este oxígeno
y este oxígeno obtiene dos pares libres
de electrones el carbono de aquí en la
derecha ahora está doblemente unido a un
oxígeno así y luego este carbono también
está enlazado con otros dos átomos o
moléculas
y el azufre el azufre ahora está unido a
este oxígeno de aquí
el azufre está unido a este oxígeno este
oxígeno tiene tres pares libres de
electrones lo que le da una carga formal
de menos 1
el azufre está unido a dos grupos metilo
y aún tiene un par libre de electrones
en él porque tuvo dos pares libres para
empezar los cuales le dan al azufre una
carga formal de más 1 así y entonces si
tú solo te enfocas en el compuesto de
azufre de aquí arriba
podrías dibujar una estructura resonante
podrías mover estos electrones para acá
y entonces si dibujó una estructura
resonante para eso ahora tendríamos
azufre
doblemente enlazado a un oxígeno de esta
manera con dos grupos metilo y teniendo
a un un par de electrones libres en el
ahora podemos reconocer eso como de ms o
sul foc sido débil metilo y entonces
producimos de ms o pero lo más
importante es
producimos estos dos carbón y los de
aquí abajo
nuevamente aldehídos o cetonas
dependiendo de lo que esté enlazados
cierto producimos estos aldehídos o
cetonas aquí
y entonces si seguimos a algunos de
nuestros electrones estos electrones en
rojo aquí a la izquierda
esos se movieron a acá a nuestro
compuesto carbónico y los electrones en
verde aquí a la izquierda eso se
movieron a acá para formar este
compuesto carbónico después de un
mecanismo extremadamente largo
finalmente llegamos a nuestra mezcla de
aldehídos y cetonas continuamos con un
ejemplo para asegurarnos de que puedas
aplicar esta reacción bien veamos un al
que no aquí está nuestro al que no y a
nuestro al que no
en el primer paso añadiremos ozono o3
y en el segundo paso añadiremos sulfuro
de dimetil o de m&s la manera en la que
debemos pensar en esta reacción o una
manera sencilla de pensar en ella déjame
continuar dibujando la nuevamente aquí
sabemos que vamos a escindir el doble
enlace sabemos que vamos a romper el
doble enlace de aquí sabemos que nuestro
doble enlace este es un grupo metilo y
por acá está un hidrógeno cierto no lo
dibujamos por aquí en el lado izquierdo
pero sabemos que está ahí vamos a
escindir este doble enlace
vamos a escindir lo justo aquí y
entonces una manera de hacerlo sería
solo borrar esa parte cierto si pensamos
en borrar esta parte de aquí y añadir un
oxígeno a cualquiera de estos carbonos
añadiremos un oxígeno justo aquí y
añadimos un oxígeno aquí abajo y es un
poco difícil verlo por lo que déjame
continuar dibujando lo nuevamente
abajo ahora tenemos un carbón hilo y
esa es una acetona y aquí arriba
tendremos un aldehído
y entonces este es nuestro producto
ahora está probablemente no es la manera
más sencilla de dibujarlo así que
continuemos y volvamos a dibujarlo de
otra manera si vamos a dibujarlo como
una cadena lineal veamos con cuántos
carbonos tendremos que lidiar tenemos 1
456 carbonos continuemos enderezando de
esa molécula un poco
tenemos uno y luego aquí tenemos una
acetona esos son dos carbonos
456 carbonos y luego tenemos nuestro
aldehído justo aquí y entonces ahí está
nuestro aldehído el cual sería este
carbono justo aquí un total de 7
carbonos 1 2 3 4 5 6 y 7 entonces esta
reacción produce un aldehído y una
acetona y repito ten cuidado con el
segundo paso y pon atención a lo que
quiere utilizar tu profesor